All right. Hello everyone. Welcome to uh
fundamentals of active inference. This
is the uh the second session on chapter
2 for this week. It's the 8th of May
and uh we're going to be going through
the first half of chapter 2 in this the
second session of uh the fundamentals of
active inference textbook. So, as ever,
I am your uh host, Fraser. So, and I see
I'm joined by Daniel and Andrew as well.
Uh, okie dokie. What I was saying just
before I recorded was that I think I'm
going to allow, you know, 10 minutes
post a session of just unrecorded
um free time. So, if anyone does want to
ask a question without being recorded,
they can they can do so. No problem. Uh,
it's always nice. Let me just quickly
start that. All righty.
Okie do. Now I'm going to share my
screen here. There's a few things I want
to show you. Just a window. Just the
KOD.
Fantastic. All right. You guys should be
seeing the KOD now. I'll just resize
things a little bit. Going to keep try
and keep an eye on the chat. Maybe
Andrew uh if you could uh differentially
Andrew and Daniel, that'd be nice to
keep an eye on the chat. It's a bit hard
to do so all at once. So we're here in
chapter two uh inside the COD. I've
taken the just a screenshot of the the
table of contents for chapter 2 just so
we can see what's going on. What I think
would be because we have two sessions on
chapter 2. What I think would be
valuable is to do the first half today
and then next session we're going to do
the next half. Uh what that amounts to
effectively is sections 2.1 and 2.2. Uh
there's all the way up to section 2.6 in
the book, but really 2.1 and 2.2 to
those are the that's the main kind of
theoretical core and the first half of
of the chapter. So that's what we're
gonna what we're going to aim to get
through today which should be nice. So
again the objectives of this session so
in chapter one we saw the idea that
perception
uh is inference quite literally that's
what perception is and there was a lot
of kind of theory introduced a lot of
terms introduced and so on this chapter
chapter 2 is really we're not
introducing a lot of new material we're
we're talking about h practically how to
do this uh inference thing for
perception only so that's really That's
the main kind of idea of chapter 2. You
know, we've told the story about what
inference is and how it is perception
and we want to be able to instantiate
this now formally. We want to talk about
it formally. So that's the point of
chapter 2.
Uh and this this is you know we will
have understood the the core of chapter
2 if we can kind of formalize the
inverse problem that we talked about
last time in chapter one. So how do we
go from observations
outcomes generated by the generative
process invert our generative model to
get beliefs about the states that
generated those observations. That's the
core that's the lynch pin of of chapter
2.
Right?
Uh now in order to do that there's a
running example which is introduced
throughout the book uh starting now.
It's it's all the way through chapter 2
and indeed beyond where we're going to
look at the simplest possible case of
this whole setup here where we're trying
to solve this inverse problem. Uh and
we're going to the simplest possible
setup is one in which we have hidden
states or rather we have one hidden
state exactly one and we have one kind
of observation we can get from that and
then that's we're going to spin up our
inference process from that uh situation
and the general sort of idea is there
isn't a nice picture of of this setup
but we're we're imagining that we're a
little creature a little agent which is
trying to look for food in the
environment and at the moment we're
we're
perceiving. We're not actually able to
act on anything just yet. Um, and we're
going to observe light intensities of a
certain kind. So, you know, there's
going to be a certain number of light
intensities out there and different
light intensities will correspond to
different sizes of food, right? So, and
what we want to do is infer what the
size of the food is that gives rise to a
specific light intensity. That's the
kind of modeling setup we're floating
around in just now. Uh
I was just sort of thinking I don't know
if there's a nice um there are several
figures related to this this whole setup
and we'll we'll go through them but
there isn't sort of a nice pedagogical
setup for the the perception only task
that we're looking at.
I'll just quickly get to because in in
the in the first part of the the chapter
we say okay what's the overall sort of
simulation structure that we're going to
be using for the the entire setup and he
he he has it very nicely I don't know
what the page is exactly it's uh
essentially well page 20
so you know this is elaborating what it
is to be doing active inference the
whole of active inference what do we do
we define the experimental setting So
what states and observations exist? We
define the generative process. How does
that generative process give rise to
observations? We define our generative
model. How does the agent believe the
world is really constituted? And then we
quote run inference. And what does that
mean? It means three things broadly. The
first thing a is that we infer hidden
states from observations. So we perceive
the world.
B is we control the generative process
by planning. we we select actions
somehow to perform on the generative
process in order to receive observations
that we would like to receive. And then
three kind is we update our the
parameters of our model that corresponds
to learning as we'll see. So that's kind
of a preview um a bit of preview content
there. Now this entire chapter is
concerned only with hidden state
inference as was chapter one but now
we're talking about how to do it using
bases rule.
So past everything else from your mind,
we're only concerned with a hidden state
observ hidden state inference
right here. Now, are there any questions
thus far? Is there anything uh that we
should uh stop and pause about just now?
Hands up if so.
>> Um I have a question.
>> Yes.
>> So um I was watching Daniel's recording
yesterday. I watched until the health.
Um so they when they were looking at the
figure two I believe there was this um
>> then observations
>> 2.1 oh hang on 2.2
>> this one right here. Yeah.
here. Um, my question was this does the
states represent the states of the
environment or states of the agent?
>> Yeah, excellent question. Um,
effectively the states I mean this is
used kind of equivocally
in some portions of active inference.
The states that we're dealing with here
are with respect to the model uh because
the agent only has access to really two
things. the outcomes from the generative
process. So its observations and its
model it has no other knowledge or no
way to know about what the reality is
beyond that the generative process. So
yes these are these are the states in
the model. Uh and I think actually if we
go to figure what is it here figure 2.4
this depicts it really nicely. So this
is the same figure we saw in chapter
one. Over here in this dash box, you've
got everything inside the agent. Over
here on the left, everything inside the
environment. The agent only has access
to stuff inside this dashed box except
for the observation that it gets from
the environment. And crucially, it has
its own model or its own way of
reasoning about the hidden state X
that's supposed to correspond to the
real hidden state Xstar out there in the
environment. So yeah, it's part of the
model is is the idea. It does get a bit
it's it's a it's a distinction that's
hard to gro initially um and it's often
glossed over in a lot of papers and so
on. So hopefully that helps.
>> Thank you. Andrew, I see you have did
you have another another followup?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I actually was a second
question, but it's kind of like related.
>> Um, this was also came up in the first u
in the first week. I watched Andrew's
session
>> and there was a question he looked at
which was asking um if uh if another
agent's internal states could be u the
external states of another agent. My
question here would be
uh what like what is the relation of the
generative process and the generative
model like is can the generative model
uh can the generative process actually
be a generative model from the different
perspective
um also like is actually the generative
process is not exactly the environment
right it's just our representation of
the environment I was confused a little
bit there too
>> yeah yeah I mean oh wow that's an
extremely fruitful question. I'll let
you uh chime in there, Andrew, because
you were involved.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Thanks. Uh so, first I do
want to quickly say uh without
disqualifying
99% of what Frasier said a moment ago
because it was all very useful. I do
want to directly answer for figure 2.2
there. That is actually the states are
um representative of the environment.
So, it's the caption for 2.2 that isn't
seen here, but it's referring to the
generative process and something. So,
this is this has nothing to do with the
agent for just this figure. We
immediately start getting into the agent
after this figure. Um, and a good thing
because there's a lot of that's all
good. There's a lot of repeated notation
we'll see throughout this textbook and
uh some of it relates to like previous
sort of more canonical uh kind of Carl
Frist uh Fristen sort of uh notation
that we see. Uh so the x asterisk uh on
the x-axis there that will usually
denote the generative process not the
generative model i.e. it denotes the the
environment states not the agents but um
>> I had misremembered I thought the star
was uh for the model instead but it's
exactly the opposite. Oh, I see. It's
always so the asterisk is always
supposed to sort of represent like this
is the true uh you know the true states
that that are generating uh the
observations y on the x-axis and then
yeah and then so if you see a x without
the asterisk that's typically going to
be referring to the the agent or the
generative models um states instead. Uh
but in any case, yeah, it's a good
question you rais and it's a little um
I I don't want to say it's philosophical
per se, but it's um but it it it does
kind of get into that kind of
perspectival
aspect of you know uh one way you can
look at it is like we as the the
researchers, the modelers here who who
are kind of doing this sort of work um
whenever we are modeling an agent and we
call that our generative model. We think
about like what kind of observations uh
is the agent receiving and what kind of
actions does it have? And so the the
observations that it receives and the
actions that it sort of outputs are
going to be uh from and to some kind of
what we could call a generative process
or an environment or otherwise. Um that
environment itself could have many
different things going on. And then our
our agent that we're modeling could have
a variety of kinds of um kind of hidden
state beliefs and and sensory receptors
or modalities for different kinds of
observations it can receive. uh such
that you know it. So basically our agent
could potentially have its own model uh
internally that does have
representations of other agents of like
the you know the the environment in a
more physical sense of what the the land
around it what it sees in its field of
vision or otherwise like so the here the
generative process is sort of can be
viewed as anything that isn't our agent
but nonetheless produces the
observations that our agent receives and
then conversely it receives the actions
that our agent elicits. So it is a very
sort of perspectable thing. And then
just a quick reference to um the other
related question of is another agent's
uh states um sort of like external
states for for our agent in question or
something along those lines. It really
just depends on like for our agent, does
it have some sort of representation of
the other agent in the environment? If
our agent is agent one and we have
another agent two in the environment, um
agent 2 is still part of the environment
for for agent one. So agent one could be
modeling or maintaining some sort of
internal representation or model of
agent 2. Um or it could view agent 2 as
just yet another thing in the
environment that elicits observations.
Um, so this this also
>> theory of mind.
>> Yeah.
>> It starts to hinge on the kinds of
things that we'll see in Sanjie's next
book and and Fristen's been writing a
monograph on this as well on the the
notion of basian mechanics. And so
something that distinguishes
statistical, classical, and quantum
mechanics from basian mechanics is that
basian mechanics is a very sort of
subjective mechanics. It's all from like
from the perspective of here what we'll
call a generative model or an agent,
right? So, it's it's really just what
can it represent? What kind of
observations can it receive? What can it
do to the environment? So, it it's
really comes back to the modeler and
what they're looking at and trying to
do. I hope that was that was useful. I
think that some of these things are a
little intuitive and start to bear out
as you read more about them or see more
applications of the concepts. Well, I'll
>> get that's actually very much close to
the heart of my research. I'm quite
interested in how agents interact with
one another and therefore you've got an
agent that's the environment from the
perspective of another agent and so on.
There's a whole big can of worms that
gets opened up there. And I will say in
in the um in in the wider theory of
active inference, it's kind of
unformalized as of yet exactly how to
think about that issue. So it is an
extremely deep um question that you
raised is uh so so thank you for that.
But we're going to have to understand
the basic framework first before we can
reason about those uh more more
complicated things. So I'll just quickly
just ground us again the core ideas of
this whole chapter and again we're not
covering the whole chapter in this
session are you know we want to be able
to talk formally about the generative
process and the generative model. So and
they're coupling. So that means
mathematically precisely how are we
conceptualizing of these things in a way
that we can begin to build them. That's
the the the the the rub really of of
chapter two. And then we want to be able
to do hidden state estimation with those
those models. So again, single state
single observation. And thank you Andrew
for pointing out my my miss uh uh on
here for figure 2.2. Yes, this is
depicting as you say the relationship
that obtains in the generative process
between the hidden states and the
observations. So
I'd like to maybe move into questions
around that relationship now because
that's really central to this this
chapter. I go back up into the notes
here. Um there's three important things.
So core idea. Yes. Unfortunately, this
is this is long enough now that I can
get lost in it, which is a little
annoying. Uh yeah, so
learning this. Here we go. So there's
there's kind of three things floating
around here. There's the observation
well the state space. What are the
states that are out there in the model
and that I'm modeling? There's the
observation space. What are the
observations that can be generated from
those states? And then I think very
importantly there's our assumptions as
modelers about the relationship between
those two spaces.
That's the crucial kind of third
connection part um that's often kind of
hard to understand uh with when you're
when you're beginning to make these
things. Those are the three things that
we're going to have to talk about. So
what do we what do we So we have this
setup where we we've got um you know
hidden hidden food sizes that give rise
to a certain light intensity. The
question that we have from the
perspective of the agent is well what on
the basis of observations of light
intensity what should we believe about
the food size right that's the question
we need to ask now and in order to
answer that question we need to make
certain assumptions about the
relationship between the light intensity
and and the food size and kind of all
all the devils all the details are in
those assumptions in some sense so uh
but again we're going to start out with
the simplest possible case so if I go
down to
uh again this
figure 2.2.
We're saying here that the environment
the real world
demonstrates a linear relationship
between uh food size and light
intensity. So as food size increases,
light intens intensity also increases in
in the same proportion. But of course uh
you know it's not a perfect mapping.
there is some kind of wiggle around the
perfect mapping uh that that are our
observations and these this comes from
the the stochastic or non-deterministic
or probabilistic nature of the mapping.
So we don't you know for a given hidden
uh food site we don't always get exactly
the same light observation we get
something you know around in the
ballpark you know by spread out by that
amount so
this and I must say it's a little bit
strange to talk about the generative
process in this way because usually we
don't well that's not quite true the
real world is in some sense the real
world we don't have to build it but if
we're if we if we have a a situation
maybe like open AAI gym or uh you know a
game engine or something like that we
have written what the real world is and
there are relationships between the
hidden states but in a lot of a lot of
situations we don't have to kind of
implement the real world we can just
directly observe the uh on the basis of
our senses what what is out there in the
real world and all of the modeling takes
place inside the uh the agent in it
generative model. So this is a picture
of the generative process. All right,
the real world in some sense. I don't
>> I don't mean to speak so much this early
but uh yeah I just I think that that's
actually such a good figure as far as
like initially getting into these things
because what we'll end up seeing is that
um once you start to add in noise uh and
we so we start departing from like a
deterministic linear equation instead we
see like oh despite you know a
potentially deterministic hidden state
of the environment um the actual
observations produced don't match that
line. So just by by having noise, it it
it creates um what we would call
something like a partially observable
environment, the agent has even the
observations it receives are not
perfectly mapped to uh a true state of
the environment. And so the agent has to
deal with kind of handling this noise.
And anyone who's familiar with the
difference between sort of ordinary
versus stochastic differential equations
um these kinds of concepts will will
probably come very intuitively but just
the sense of like the agent actually has
to have some sense of like the the
environment potentially being noisy. And
then finally uh that'll kind of show the
benefits of using kind of a basian
framework where we're able to kind of
keep and maintain uh uncertainty itself
as a core part of the environment uh
excuse me as a core part of the agent as
opposed to um the agent itself having a
deterministic mapping that could be you
know incredibly wrong and misguided uh
in certain noisy situations. So much of
the world is genuinely noisy, right? So
that's the part of the appeal of the
framework. That's that's all I have
>> precisely. Yeah. And I just want to
maybe highlight I don't know if we want
to step through each and every equation,
but the first kind of equation in this
in this chapter is 2.1 where we're we're
expressing mathematically the idea that
we have about how the generative process
really works. So it's some function of
the hidden state, the parameters, right?
And then there's some added noise here.
And that's exactly the picture that we
saw if we go back up to chapter two here
figure 2.2 kind of the the spread in the
vertical direction is exactly that noise
right so that's that's where the noise
is coming from for sure
okie do now the next sort of thing is I
guess equation 2.2 to that's on page uh
23.
Again, I don't want to step through them
all in sequence. It's going to take too
long, but it is important because it
highlights the problem we were talking
about. Do we have 2.2 in the in the
coder? We may not just yet. Uh it's okay
because it's in 2.3.
>> Yeah, all all equations should be there.
So,
>> yeah. Well, it's it's in 2.10. We can
use 2.10 as the as the idea. This is a
sector. This is basically you know our
assumption about how the world works.
Well, this this is in fact how the world
works. It turns out that the
observations y are given by some
function of the hidden states. What is
the function of the hidden states? Well,
it's some number plus another number
times the hidden state. This is a linear
relationship here. I' I'm not going to
get into what linear and nonlinear means
just now because there's an important
example that comes up later that that
demonstrates it. But this is the
relationship that obtains in the real
world. Okay, this is what the real world
is actually like for this example and
that is the generative process or rather
it's how observations are generated by
the generative process.
Very nice. So that's in some sense the
model and there's there's questions
around maybe notation of certain things.
Uh we can go through that as well really
2.4 is the most complete uh or final um
representation. There was a question
about you know what is the I go to the
questions here questions questions
[clears throat] there was a question
about what is the difference between uh
the structural and probabilistic form of
the the model so
here we go and there is no difference
basically they're just two different
ways of emphasizing the same thing in
slightly different notation so they're
not really fundamentally different ideas
however if you're unsure about which
sort of idea or or way of representing
the environment you should get used to.
I would recommend getting used to the
probabilistic form because that will
show up more frequently um throughout
the book. So go back to chapter two. All
right. So that's the that's the process
the model. This is where all the
interesting stuff happens effectively.
So this is very much you know our
assumption about how we think the
generative process works. So, if I go
down to I don't want to go to figure 2.5
just yet because that is there's a few
more things to get sorted there.
But equation 2.7 that is the model.
That's one thing to to look at. That's
the last equation I want to look at in
in much detail.
2.2 maybe there's a way of getting this
to be numerically uh sorted.
>> Yeah, they're they're all in order.
Pretty sure.
>> Yeah. Okay. Beautiful.
Okay. So this is the model. This is our
assumptions about how we think the world
works. How we think observations are
generated from the world. So and
crucially it's expressed in terms of the
language of Bas's rule which we saw from
from chapter one where we've got kind of
four things. We have a a belief about
how observations are generated from the
the process. we have a prior belief
about what we think the the world is
like before we've seen any observations.
Uh and then we have kind of the model
itself in some sense or at least the
observation model. This is what we think
the relationship is between hidden food
size and light intensity. So we think as
little agents that you know the light
intensity is given by this relationship
here. And that's actually correct in
this in this instance. So we saw before
that the generative pro process has
exactly the same relationship between
the observation and the hidden state. It
need not be exactly the same and very
often the model that the agent has of
the process will be different and it
will be simpler than the real process.
Uh and we'll see reasons why but it will
it will very often not be the same. In
this case it is exactly the same just
for pedagogical convenience. And then
all he's done down here in these last
two lines is package up the various
parameters uh of the
the expressions in in questionure. We
can go through that if there's
uncertainty about that. And this this uh
this is how the models and the processes
are notated in in the rest of the book
are in a certainly in a very large chunk
of of the rest of the book. So it is it
is good to get used to these ways of
expressing things for now.
Now, how do we perform hidden state
inference? Can anyone tell me? I'm going
to be I'm going to be not passive
aggressive, but I'm going to uh raise a
question for the group. Does anyone
remember how we do hidden state
inference in in the ideal case?
Going once, going twice. It's a bit of a
trick question.
No takers. What about Andrew?
[gasps]
ideally right so this is the key this is
the key word how would how would we do
hidden state inference in the most ideal
case
>> in the most ideal case um I'm I'm guess
I'm going to make my best state
inference that you're referring to doing
something like an exact analytic basian
update that is we actually consider the
entire joint space between our x's and
our y's which in chapter 2 is presented
in a very simple scenario where we have
a single X variable and a single Y
variable and then you know we have a
couple parameters in the mix that that
kind of shape that relationship between
the environment and the agent. Um but
yes uh as we also know uh exactitude is
not usually feasible as soon as we get
into more real world situations where
there are more variables involved and
and you know so there many other things
to be considered and suddenly things
start to break if you go for a single
analytic solution. I think
>> that's my
>> that's what I was fishing for like the
in the in the exact perfect sense what
we would do in order to solve the
inverse problem is we'd use Bas's rule.
That's that's exactly what we would do.
I've got it up on the screen here. This
is from chapter one. Um this tells us
and again I'm I'm going to try and be
consistent. So X refers to a state, Y
refers to an observation. So this is
precisely what we do. But in the general
case we can't do this. We need we need
to kind of get around the fact that this
is too hard to do. And we'll talk about
why it's too hard to do just now. Um so
instead like 2.1.4 inferring hidden
states. This is really where the the
rubber hits the road about uh you know
what we're doing in in this in this
portion here. So
in order to actually use bases rule I
want to get to equation 2.8 that is
important.
Uh
2.1 blah blah blah blah
2.8 2.8 2.8
because it shows uh I have a little
interlude about a process that's very
important to understand. Uh do we have
2.8 somewhere 78? Here we go. Okay. So
again this is just bases rule. Uh all
we've done is we've we expressed the
numerator as a joint probability
distribution. Uh this is our generative
model by the way. So P of X and Y, P of
the hidden state and observation. That
is your generative model. And we'll see
how to construct that. Most generally,
it's kind of broken down or factorized
into two components. We have our belief
about how hidden states are generated
from observations. And we this is our
likelihood. We call this a likelihood.
And we have our prior belief about what
hidden states are before observing
anything. And then we have to divide by
this thing P of Y. Okay, this P of Y,
this is called the um the the model
evidence. Uh and this is the hard thing
to do in invasion inference. It's
usually the thing that's impossible to
do actually and it motivates why we're
going to need variational free energy
later. But again, we haven't seen that
just yet. So this model evidence thing
down here, well in some sense the whole
thing is, you know, how likely is a
given uh observation
uh from a given hidden state multiplied
by how likely is a given hidden state
before seeing an observation divided by
the probability of seeing that that
observation at all from any hidden
state. Okay, now that hasn't elucidated
the problem very much, but the problem
lies in how do we know the like the the
probability of observing an observation
from any given hidden state. It turns
out you have to do this in order to find
that p of y, you have to go through this
process called marginalization.
So if I go up here to my notes, I have
an interlude here.
So we're down in 2.1.4
inferring hidden states. This is how we
get that marginal belief. So I'd
actually like to
show instead there's a nice figure uh
later actually this one here. So I'm
jumping ahead a little bit and this
might be a bit too fast uh and please
please do say so if it's the case. So
what are we what are we looking at here?
We're looking at our belief or rather
our generative model about the
relationship between food size and light
intensity. Okay. So on this axis we have
food size goes from 0 to 500. This axis
here we have light intensity 0 to 500.
And our model is that this is what we
think the relationship is between the
two of them. In this case it happens to
be a two-dimensional normal
distribution. Okay that's the particular
choice that we've made. If we look uh if
we look at this this red curve
this is also a marginal belief about in
this case just what the hidden state is.
So what do we do? We start from the
generative model and we say all right I
can from that try and determine what I
think the hidden state is
uh or what I think the observation is.
[clears throat] Okay and and in order in
order to do that that process is called
marginalization. So in this case the the
red is uh is is the belief about the
hidden state. You can imagine sort of
looking from the food size axis down
along the light intensity axis and kind
of casting a shadow. That's then the
marginal belief about hidden states for
all possible food sizes. Right? But as
we saw on the denominator of Bas's rule,
we really care about the marginal over
this side here. So if I look along the
light intensity axis, so if I'm looking
at if I'm trying to form a belief about
what the light intensity is for any
given food size at all, I have to
project along this direction and I'll
get some sort of bell shape here. Right?
That's the marginal. It's called a
marginal because these are in some sense
the margins of the probability
distribution. And historically people
would write this on a page and they
would literally write it in the margins.
sort of why it's called marginal. That's
how you would get your marginal belief
about uh the the light intensity from
any given food size. In general, it's
impossible to calculate this. There's
too many hidden states to worry about.
Usually, um so I hope that that gives a
little bit of intuition about where this
marginal belief comes from. The way that
we solve it in this chapter is we just
sort of pretend or well we don't
pretend. We we do this thing called grid
approximation where we take this nice
and smooth generative models. It's a
very smooth thing, continuous thing and
we chop it up into lots of little
discrete pieces, right? So you might
imagine that we've chopped it up into
500 pieces here, right? So we can do we
can do 500 things. That's not too bad.
Okay, but we can't do well we in in
general it's going to be too hard to go
about solving this problem by chopping
up our generative model into lots of
little parts.
So as the last as the last thing there
on marginalization
what that corresponds to mathematically.
So that was kind of the the intuition.
Hopefully you can see this here. Maybe
I'll zoom in a bit.
You know if you've got your joint
distribution your generative model and
we want to get the marginal belief about
observations from the generative model.
Literally what what it means to
marginalize is we add up all of the ways
that Y our observation Y could have
happened across all values of the hidden
state. Right? So what is that? Well, if
it let's imagine that there's n hidden
states capital N, it's the probability
of X1 and Y plus the probability of X2
and Y plus the probability blah blah
blah blah blah all the way up to XN and
Y. that will give you the probability of
Y in the case that we have in the case
that we can chop up the the hidden
states. That's kind of what
marginalization is mathematically. And
that's usually very very very hard to
do. Indeed, it's often impossible to do
for for most interesting problems. But
this problem is simple enough that we
can do it kind of directly. So
that's a lot and that's a very crucial
um articulation point of understanding
in the chapter. I just like to pause
here for a second if there's any any
questions or any uncertainty around what
any of that meant. Um that is quite a
central idea and again we're going to
see ways around this problem later uh by
means of talking about free energy
variational free energy.
>> Andrew, please.
I just wanted to briefly say, and I've
I've probably brought it up before, so
I'll try not to bring it up too much,
but um at the the bottom of the the
figures page, I've added these uh slides
if anyone finds them useful where um
just a couple of slides per chapter.
Yeah. Um but for for chapters one and
two, I just do some more basic things
like talk about what is the difference
between discrete and continuous
variables. In chapter 2, here we're
we're focusing on continuous variables.
Um, I appreciate that you made the point
about grid approximation because that'll
come up uh in other methods for
discretizing
um spaces and so um all I mean to say
with that is that a a property of
continuous probability distributions at
least as far as we're looking at like
these kind of normal or Gaussian
distributions is that the probability of
any single individual point on a
continuous distribution like that is
always necessarily ly zero. Meaning that
you know if you kind of keep it in that
state, it's almost not useful if you
want to get some kind of point estimate
or something like if we say what is what
is the probability of of this given that
the state was 2.4. Uh well, we we don't
know its probability zero. Um and so we
always kind of have to what what you can
do is that you can retrieve some kind of
nonzero probability by saying rather
than x being exactly equivalent to some
float value you could say x is between
uh you know 0.1 and 0.2 or something
along those lines. Once you once you
start kind of splicing up the state
space then you can actually start
talking about real probability values.
But all these things get into sort of uh
sort of the basics of of probability
theory which um despite me using the
word basics can can be quite a a bit to
think about but it's useful getting into
because it's you know heavily relied
upon in active inference and elsewhere.
>> Yeah I just thank you for that Andrew.
Um I just wanted to point out figure 2.3
here. So this is a visual representation
of what we're doing when we're doing
this grid approximation thing. We're
just saying look let's take our nice
smooth continuous belief and chop it up
into evenly spaced points that we'll
sort of uh not sample but we'll we'll
we'll consider these these discrete
points here and do do the necessary
calculations uh with these discrete
points. Uh so that's that's shown in
equation 2.9.
Um again I don't want to get too
sidetracked by that notation but it is
important.
Uh 2.9 here we go. So what we do is we
chop up our our distribution into a
bunch of points and we say let's
evaluate our uh our observation belief
on those points. So this is saying you
know when we got P of Y is equal to Y
hat this is saying what's the
probability that our observation is
equal to this particular exh value Y hat
right maybe that's some value right
that's that's all that means really so
this is how we'll actually approximate
the you know bases rule get it to be
used in this in this chapter 2.9 I see
there was a question in the chat just
want to quickly check that would you
speak more to the reason that it is
impossible to relate
uh to PFY. Yeah. So, we're we're
actually going to see this is a
continuing theme uh throughout a lot of
the book. The reason why marginalization
and and evaluating the model evidence,
again, that bottom term that's called
the model evidence. The reason why
that's so hard is usually because the
kinds of problems we're looking at are
not like this. They are not come come
here. What am I doing? I'm doing
this one. I want to go back to that
figure 2.14.
So this is an extremely small problem.
There's really only one kind of hidden
state. You know, usually the kinds of
problems we care about, especially for
like robotics problems, there are
thousands or if not millions of hidden
states. Uh and in order to be able to
perform that mathematical operation,
that summing, right? Or in the case of a
continuous distribution integrating
there just ends up being exponentially
an exponentially large number of things
you have to do. you have to account for
all of the possible hidden states that
could possibly have given rise to any
given observation and usually that's
just impossible. Um I think for next
session I'll try and I'll find a few
concrete kind of you know examples maybe
from my research as well um
demonstrating why that's impossible. It
it does sound a little bit implausible
like well why can't we just do it? Uh
but it turns out we really just cannot
do it in in in a lot of problems. uh and
it's this example obscures that fact
precisely because it was contrived to be
easy enough to do. Exactly. So hopefully
that gives some sort of question there
is yes please. Um I was wondering if
this has any relation to um I was
recently taking a machine learning
course and we were my professor was
explaining
um he first explained the ideal case of
where we know the joint distribution
uh we were maximum likelihood estimation
but then he said because we actually do
not have the real uh joint distribution
we um create two models to estimate the
parameters is there and we move on from
there. Uh is this related is part of the
reason maybe why we can find that margin
of the probability of Y is it because we
actually do not have the real um joint
distribution.
>> Well, yeah, we uh what we're going to
see is that we we have a joint
distribution obviously this P of X and Y
that we're treating as our generative
model. uh and it if we use grid
approximation for this very simple case,
we can just directly use um the form of
the model that we we care about to do
marginalization.
Uh but later on that's going to become
impossible. So we need a different way
to do that and we're going to introduce
this idea of variational inference where
we have uh some distribution right that
we we posit as the real distribution
that we should be using and we're going
to minimize the distance between that
distribution and the real one somehow.
So there's there's actually a very large
number of uh tools and a whole suite of
theory about how to do that. There's
many different ways of talking about
that problem. But that flavor of problem
comes up again and again. Um, and we're
going to look at a particular way of
formulating that kind of problem uh
later. Yes,
Andrew, real quick.
>> Yeah, thanks. Uh, yeah. Uh again we'll
see more about uh these things uh in in
later chapters but uh I could say
quickly that um yeah so so if I
understand the question correctly it
might be that um you know the idea is
that we don't know the full joint
probability distribution of the
environment. Um and so we're we're
having to sort of update things and
update parameters and so on. And so in
chapter 3, the immediate next chapter
we'll be getting into uh a couple weeks
from now. Um that'll be about learning
parameters and then it's a very holistic
chapter. So it already quickly
reintegrates all the the state inference
that we learn in chapter 2 with um
parameter inference what we'll call
learning uh in chapter 3. And we'll see
this uh this algorithm that's a very
famous algorithm known as expectation
maximization. It's sort of this two-step
iterative process where first you
estimate a hidden state and then in step
two you update your parameters given
that hidden state and then you use those
parameters to return back to step one
reestimate your state. So you're just
back and forth between hidden state
estimation, which we find a lot of in
chapter 2, with parameter learning in
chapter 3. And that's what will
hopefully presumably allow us to better
approximate the true joint distribution.
That is our model or agent will
eventually start to sort of synchronize
or better uh uh sort of reflect the true
uh generative process even though we
don't necessarily have any proof of
that. um unless you know we we are the
modelers and set up the generative pro
process ourselves in which case we can
see how well it sort of performs and
actually benchmark that which is the
value of figure 2.2 two we saw earlier,
right, of seeing, well, this is what the
generic process actually looks like. We
have access to that. So, and then there
are some nice guarantees that we sort of
get whenever we do some of the later
parts of chapter 2 that we'll probably
get into next week, including like using
gradient descent and maximum likelihood
estimation as well as maximum a
posteriori which is almost equivalent to
to MLE except you're also including a
prior which is again something we see in
the the basine framework. So um there
are some sort of guarantees that you'll
at least hit some kind of local minima
for those who are familiar with that
concept. Um but uh yeah again that's
that's much much more material to come
on that end.
>> No for sure there is there is quite a
lot. Well the last sort of 15 minutes
here I think what's really important to
cover is example 2.1 2.2 and 2.3. I
think those are really the core of the
latter half of uh section 2.2. So what
we're doing with 2.1, we're we're just
taking the setup now and we're looking
at different modeling assumptions about
what we think the generative process is
like. So I've got equation uh 2.1 up on
the screen now. This is a particular
model about what we think the generative
process is like. This notation here I'm
not going to explain. But what we're
basically saying or at least I'm not
going to explain in this session just
now. We're saying that look our belief
about what we think the observation is
uh given by is not in fact a nice kind
of smooth thing. We're just we're going
to believe that we get exactly one kind
of observation from exactly one kind of
hidden state. Um and it's kind of like
this prick that we're looking at. This
is called a direct delta distribution.
So what this looks like visually if I go
back to chapter 2 this is figure 2.7
uh which is up here up here there we go
so you know our our belief about the how
observations are generated given hidden
states again it's this sort of prick at
a certain uh you know value for for
fruit size our prior belief is this is
this is what's known as a uniform
distribution so we what we believe about
the food size
uh given observations is that we don't
have any particular you know sort of uh
prior assumptions about the relationship
between food size and light intensity.
Uh so we're kind of open-minded in some
sense about what the real relationship
is. Now when we get an observation from
uh well from from our interface with
with the generative process we use the
prior and the likelihood together to
form a belief about what we think the
the real food size is given an
observation and that's called our
posterior belief that's over here on the
right. So once we get an observation in
uh we we now believe that the food size
is about 3.5 right? But here's the
problem. This is what this is uh this is
not accounting for any uncertainty here
this model we have assumed that there's
no well we have assumed there's no
uncertainty about about things this this
is kind of a big problem with this model
and if we go to 2 uh two now now we
actually look at
uh figure 2
10 y
this is exactly the same model except
now we are we're allowing allowing for
there to be uncertainty in our beliefs.
Okay, so you can see that our
probabilities and I'm going to use the
term probabilities and belief or
probability distribution and belief
equivocally. There is a bit of subtlety
around that, but just for the sake of
being able to not have to explain
everything all the time. Our beliefs are
kind of spread out a bit more. So here
we have a prior belief that's centered
around four being the true hidden food
size before we've seen any any evidence.
And our likelihood model is telling us
that uh we believe it the hidden food
size should be two. Once we get an
observation in uh I believe it is shown
in the text here.
I'll have to find it exactly the the
parameters of these distributions are
given in the equations. Then we can see
our our belief after having observed an
observation this posterior is now this
green distribution here. Okay. And
that's very much uh a visual depiction
of the results of bases rule. Okay. So
bases rule is operative here, but we're
not really seeing how it's operative.
We're kind of seeing the results of it,
which is a little bit annoying to see. I
will I will post a bit of stuff in the
uh in the questions area to to motivate
that a bit more. The last thing I want
to talk about then uh before I open it
up for for some quick questions is
example 2.3.
This is exactly the same situation.
So I go back here now for 2.11.
This is precisely the same example
except all we've done now is we've made
the prior belief uh well there's kind of
two versions of example 2.11. On the top
row we've got a prior belief that's very
very very certain that the the the true
food size is four. And there's very
little uncertainty about that. You can
see the the the spread of the
probability distribution is not very
much. uh and you know we have a
likelihood that's a little bit more
spread out. So we're we're willing to
sort of update our beliefs a bit and you
can see that in this case where we're
very certain about our prior beliefs
we're very stubborn. Um even when we get
observations in they don't change our
beliefs very much. The posterior is very
similar to the prior here. Uh so this
this is kind of simulating an agent
that's unwilling to change its mind.
It's got very very strong prior beliefs.
Whereas on the bottom row, we have
exactly the inverse situation where the
prior is a bit more spread out. It's
kind of a bit more open-minded, right?
Uh and instead it has a very precise,
very certain likelihood model about how
hidden states um generate observations.
So when we get an observation in now, we
can see that uh the agent's much more
willing to trust the observation because
it's open-minded and it updates its
belief quite a lot from this very spread
out prior to this very precise one here.
So this this example is demonstrating
the effect that the amount of
uncertainty that you have on your prior
beliefs and also your likelihood beliefs
about how observations are generated
from hidden states. This significantly
affects how you change your mind, how
you update your beliefs about what those
hidden states are. So that's again
that's another kind of very big hinge
point in in this chapter. So
there is then uh another example which I
would like to talk about but I'd like to
just maybe quickly ask if there are any
questions about that situation there. We
can go through some of the maths if you
wanted to. Um there are you know there's
there's equations that express those
ideas as well. ever
be a lot. Um, yeah, thanks. Just only in
reference to to figure 2.10 you were
looking at there, I just wanted to sort
of reiterate, uh, from earlier in this
session like the the the importance of
noise and whenever we're dealing with
like noisy processes. And so, um, we can
start to see how one of the limitations
of maximum likelihood estimation, which
is where we're effectively only using
the likelihood. we're not doing anything
regarding like um P of X or like prior
over X. Um that's great potentially in a
noiseless environment because then we
can make a clear assumption almost you
know it could be a linear assumption,
nonlinear assumption but whatever it is
we imagine some kind of like nice line
however curvy or straight it might be
that describes the relationship between
X and Y which is your likelihood. Um, if
that were reliable and there were no
noise, then you could potentially get
very good estimates of of sort of the
potential true uh hidden state hidden
state of the environment through that.
Um but then of course the issue is like
if for those who are interested in say
robotics for some or something like that
a robot who has sensory receptors let's
say there's a malfunction for a moment
in a sensory receptor and instead of
light intensity being a nice two or
three or four it skyrockets to you know
12,000 right? Um, if the agent only
relies upon its likelihood and assumes a
really nice linear relationship, it's
going to assume that the food size
really is 12,000. Uh, even though that's
a very, you know, what actually might be
a non-existent impossible value, right?
Because um because of the noise, right?
The the noise that comes from the
sensory receptor. So, by having priors,
it instead allows the agent to be a
little bit more robust to noise. It
says, "Oh, well, you know, usually I
think that there's a 1:1 relationship
between the state and the observation,
but actually because I'm pretty well
centered in my priors that here here's a
nice more realistic set of uh x values
uh that that I think it tends to be. Um
the the prior can help balance out uh
the noise that that we get that would
impact only using the likelihood. So,
um, yeah, it's just robustness to sort
of noise and then the benefits of being
able to include uncertainty in your in
your modeling, uh, approach. But, uh,
>> that's a that's a great point, Andrew. I
I I there's a lot of there's actually a
lot of very excellent reasons why the
many that's one of the many excellent
reasons why you want to include um, the
ability to reason about uncertainty in
your model. Uh, because you get this
kind of robustness as well. So, thank
you for that, Andrew. Um but so we'll
see more about you know we haven't
talked about maximum likelihood
estimation just yet that comes up in
sort of section 2.5 and onwards um there
ways of doing this inference ways of
solving the inference problem without uh
well with and without explicitly
reasoning about the uncertainty and
issue there's some subtlety around that
we'll see that next time in next session
the only other thing uh quickly in the
last few minutes here before I take
questions uh is and this this is a very
nice demonstration here if we Look at
example 2.4.
So I'd like to go to equation 2.15. This
is the last equation I'll show. 2.15.
Here we go. No. Really?
Ah yes that is correct.
So this is we're now looking at a
different generative process here. We're
looking at a different world. Okay. So
the idea here is exactly the same as
before. We have the observations are
given by some number plus some other
number times some function of the hidden
state. Okay, before we had a number plus
a number times the hidden state, you
know, just a linear thing. This kind of
looks linear, but this function thing,
what is this doing? This is just a
notation for saying take the hidden
state and multiply it by itself.
So the generating function in this case
the thing that generates observations is
a number plus a number times the hidden
state squared. Okay, this is no longer
linear. This is this is a different
generating function. This is going to
cause now so so that's that's what the
environment is really like in this case.
If we take I believe it is 2
uh
2.16
This is then the model. Okay.
In this case, the model has
recapitulated that same assumption. We
think the real world is given by our
observations are given by exactly the
same relationship that would obtain uh
in the model in this case and 2.13 if I
go to figure 2.13
this illustrates something interesting
is then the result of this visually. So
uh 2.13
go.
So now we see you know we have the same
uniform prior as in the first example
but our likelihood has now two spikes
uh with respect to where we think uh
observations are are given by hidden
states and our posterior then also has
two spikes. This doesn't make sense
physically. Uh you can't have negative
food size. That's an artifacts of our
modeling assumption. So we'd only in
practice we'd only care about the
positive side. Uh but something very
interesting happens when you don't when
you have a mismatch between the model
and the process. So if I go it is 2.18
and 2.19
figure 2.16
just want to quickly show this. I think
this [snorts] is this is the
kind of crux here. What we're looking at
here is the result of using model 2.19
where we have a linear relationship. So
we we assume that observations are given
by a linear relationship in the hidden
states when actually in the generative
process they're given by a quadratic or
nonlinear relationship. So there's a
mismatch now between how the
observations are really generated and
how we think they're generated. So you
know the true food so the true fruit
size is given by this dotted line here.
we have and all of these beliefs by the
way these are all posterior beliefs. So
these are beliefs after Basa's rule has
happened. So in the case where the true
fruit size is two you can see that the
updated belief is actually quite wrong.
Our model is not correct in this case.
In the case where the true food size is
2.5, okay, our model is a little bit
better. You can see it's closer to that
dotted line. But if we go, you know,
slightly beyond that to 3.5, now we're
we're very wrong again. So this this is
elucidating the idea that, you know,
even though our model is wrong, it can
be useful for food sizes that are close
to around about two or so, right? Uh so
there's this issue, there's this
question, you know, how how wrong should
our model be? It's it's kind of an open
question. We'll see other other ways of
thinking about how to deal with that uh
later. But I think that that was an
important thing to show. I would
recommend looking at 2.18 and 2.19 those
two equations to see uh formally where
where where the results of this have
come from.
All right, we are currently at time. Um
technically that has got me to 2.3. So I
think next session we'll start going
through thinking about how to extend
this to multiple uh samples. So we'll go
2.3 all the way to 2.6. six which is the
sort of summary chapter we'll talk about
maximum likelihood estimation and kind
of nonbe we'll get a flavor of some
nonbeigian ways to do things ultimately
that is not going to be how we approach
the problem of inference we are very
much wanting to be in a bayian setting
but it's good to be aware of the other
ways of doing things uh for sure and
we'll talk a little bit more about
marginalization
so that is it for this session
uh I will stop the recording here but if
uh well first of Is there anyone who
would like to ask a question on on the
recording? I think we can go uh for at
least another five minutes on the
recording.
If not, I will uh I will end the
recording here and then I'll stay on.
Okay. Isan. Yes, please. Far away.
>> Okay. So, my question is uh Michael
Leven talks about this bow tie structure
um of agents when they are um recalling
memories. So he was [clears throat]
>> for example when you're remembering
something
>> um it's just constant reinterpretation.
Um and what I got from that is there is
kind of like no distinction of my
memories observation versus a a state um
observing a state from the environment.
Uh
>> yeah that that's my question. Is there
actually any difference in this uh
active inference or no?
>> Well, this is this is an ex again a very
massively deep and important question. I
I love the work of Michael Lean in that
regard for sure. Um if I understand you
correctly uh I it's been a while since
I've uh listened to him talk about this.
I would I would equate the model that we
have. Right? So well this is not showing
these are showing the results of our
model. I would equate the models that
we're using with our memories about how
we think the world is like, you know,
they're sort of like our priors. So
that's kind of the role that Michael
Leven's notion of memory would would
fulfill in this case. This is
constraining what we think is possible
and that's kind of the role of the prior
here. Um, at least that's what I think.
Andrew, do you have do you have a
perspective on that?
Yeah, I I I would probably second your
point just now, Frasier, that the this
would be sort of be some kind of like uh
representation or otherwise of the
agent's memory for sure. Especially
whenever we think about well it both the
prior and the likelihood, right? because
this would um whenever we get into like
parameter learning and all the rest
we'll start to see that um often times
one way that we we do parameter learning
will actually be through accumulation of
more experience. And so you can think of
accumulation of experience as if you're
sort of adding to your memory or at
least sort of slowly shaping your memory
uh or your model of the environment that
you have over time. Um, that said, I was
a little unclear on the phrasing of the
question with reference to um, I mean,
as far as we get into something like the
the biology or neurobiology or
physiology of memory, then then it does
start to be the case that um, you know,
sort of remembering a particular
observation may not be recalled in the
same way every time. Uh, and so that
presents like kind of a new slew of
potential problems. I mean you can have
these kind of pristine ideal models
where that simply isn't the case.
There's like no sort of decay so to
speak or changes in the the memory. Uh
or it could be something very different.
Depends on how closely kind of uh
neurobiologically plausible you want
your your model to be. And I'm so so
there are people who are working on
things that relate to like memory decay
or sort of reshaping or we might even
implicitly say that an observation even
in these models that we're looking at
can be very differently evaluated at a
later point in time after more
accumulation of different kinds of
experience. Could we say that that means
whenever that memory is being recalled,
it's no longer equivalent to what it
once was? Like in a sense, yes. It no
longer fits in the same scheme. The
scheme's been updated. The parameters
have been updated. There might even been
some sort of structure learning process
where they're no longer like model isn't
even kind of shaped the same way or
structured the same way. So that's all
good. I was a little curious though
about the the reference to directly
observing a state in the environment.
I'm not sure if that's that's how you
phrased it or not but uh my
>> yeah if I may um so I if I can like
articulate my question a little better.
So this uh we talked about noise right?
What I was thinking for example that
noise could be coming from um the
reasons from the environment or the
reasons from the actual like the
internal um states and for example when
I'm re-reme remembering a memory
constantly every time I'm changing as
you referenced but
>> um that maybe we can think that as noise
but does the agent have any um way of
distinguishing
um what is the source of this object
observation behind that like blanket
maybe like when I'm doing this
observation is the source coming from an
an internal state or outside of like
from the environment.
>> Yeah. So, so the the um sort of with
like chapter one and talking about
perception since we're kind of you know
needing different kinds of ways almost
to talk about these things. um the agent
essentially receives observations and
then is trying to infer the hidden
states or we could also call them hidden
causes of those observations. So if the
agent has you know uh you know based on
its structure the kind of structures
that we're looking at here if the agent
had you know uh some hidden state rep
just as this model has a hidden state
representation of food size um if we had
an agent who had a a representation of
how hungry it is as a hidden state and
then the observation is how much is my
stomach growling you know so we can
think of you know starts to sound, oh,
this is more about the agent, right? At
least in a colloquial typical sense.
We're not thinking about what's outside
of the agent. We're thinking about
literally what is physically inside of
the agent and producing observations.
But even then, the agent still is just
maintaining an internal representation
in its model of how it's sort of
stomach, you know, works or or what its
metabolic rate needs to be or or
something along the something that
relates to hunger. So ultimately it's
still more of um an internal
representation. It's not actually m you
so you can look at this agent's own body
as part of the environment in a sense.
It's like the agent's just maintaining
its beliefs about its body just as it
has to maintain beliefs about anything
else. And I not to overload this but um
you know you could think of like young
infants and children like they're still
learning how to sort of operate their
body right and how it works. It's like
it's almost a skill to be able to like
read what's going on internally within
you. So it's very we call that
interosception
in sort of the the psychology. Um and so
and then exterception would be things
that you sort of receive from the
colloquial outside through your senses
such as sight, sound and all the rest.
But interosceptive would sort of be
what's coming from within the body. And
then finally there's proprioception
which has to do a little bit more with
the the kinetics of uh of physical
movement. So yeah, it's a it's it's a
big topic but it's a very interesting
question to bring up. It's it many
papers that kind of discuss these sorts
of things. Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Active inference purports to to you know
be something that can account for you
know this exterior receptive
interiorceptive
all those meal domains and modalities of
inference. So we are at the moment we're
just concerned with exterior receptive
inference for sure.
>> On on page 364 there's a little bit of
historical sort of context around
interior receptive inference. uh could
be of interest. So that's in that's way
that's in chapter 13 quite quite deep
into the book for sure.
>> Yeah,
>> thank you very much.
>> No problem.
>> Any more questions? I do want to let
people ask some questions without the
recording as well.
[clears throat]
All right, I'll stop sharing my screen.
Ah, I'm not sharing my screen.
Interesting. Seems to boot you off after
a while. Okay. Well, thank you guys.
I'll stop the recording here. Uh, anyone
who does want to ask a question, uh, you
know, live after we've recorded, no
problem. Uh, but we will we will see you
all next week starting from section 2.3.
So, thank you very much. I'll stop the
recording now. And there we go.